there could be yelling today the energy
in here is palpable Josh took a flight
left go and Sims been yelling at each
other all morning didn't am a Sims loves
Amazon it's too big Instagram guy
you shut your first Instagram video
today oh it's really monumental moment
you look different now do I
hey you look I got a coupon hipper yeah
millennial you don't look do you have
trees on your sweatshirt once again
hello let's welcome back I'll actually
love this you don't like that's great
all right sis I'm tellin ya I'm tellin
ya why is it palpable I don't understand
we've been having great conversation
where you lying to the people who are
listening right now that's my point
that's why your body language is off my
voice is so calm but why are you lying
to the viewers right now do people
actually watch yeah a lot of people on
YouTube I'd listen I wouldn't watch fej
what's that you know I'm watching things
now I don't doesn't I like watching me
yep I don't well I come in to come in
the house in the morning after I do like
the pro football talk show my wife will
like have it on like because she's like
started it late and I just walk over to
the TV and turn it off I just can't look
at myself is Danielle watch every
morning now you're on she puts it on the
TV it's how a tricked commitment it's a
trick Fenric was just in Austin and he
had the chance to hear Mack Brown yeah
because when a number of people at
bleach report yeah and me and Sims have
been waiting to hear if he talked about
Chris yes you've already heard I do not
know talking about Chris so a couple
funny things that happened just to set
it out for everybody the entire bleacher
report sales team is in Austin right now
for our sales summit sales offset how
much did we pay mack brown to have him
sleep good question only got 70 billion
in the bank don't know but i'll ask and
how about the next week's podcast so
anyway our motivational speaker was mack
brown so BK head of sales or SVP of
sales here at bleacher report is up he's
giving max intro he's talking about all
his credentials everything he does in
the community and then right before he
introduces Mack
and also Mac had the honor of coaching a
Heisman Trophy winner Chris I mean Ricky
Williams so ladies and gentlemen Mack
Brown room erupted turned around did not
see Mack laughing do not think he
thought it was funny I don't think it's
funny either actually I'm surprised
bleacher report knew I worked there
those salespeople that's good to know so
then at the end of the speech Mac was
giving his cue a and one of the
salespeople raised their hands and asked
who was the toughest recruit that Mac
ever landed and why and he said it was
you yeah he said that because you were
committed to Tennessee
yeah and that because he was also
recruiting Eli at the same time right
and that you were the number one recruit
in the country so he felt like he needed
to land you to prove how cool Texas was
right that you were the most difficult
guy he ever yeah and he actually he gave
up at one point he didn't he stopped
well because he was in North Carolina so
my junior year he was at the head coach
in North Carolina and then my senior
year he went to Texas and we had you
know I was interested in North Carolina
they were good at that time they were
kind of challenging Florida State at the
need for the ACC at that time if you
guys remember and he goes to Texas and I
think there was a time where he thought
I wouldn't go that far
you know back in those days such as
crazy I'm saying that like people didn't
go across the country to go to college I
was certainly the only kid in the
Northeast that went down to that part of
the country to play college football
that was like a rare thing people are
like whoa you're going to Texas and so
he stopped recruiting me and you know
finally one of the the tight ends coach
Tim Brewster who's now at Texas A&M with
Jimbo Fisher he he called one day
because he had played with my dad and
the giant so they kinda had a
relationship too and it's like yeah he
was like Mack Mack just thought you had
a fly over to many schools to come down
to Texas and still do that and I was
like no I was like I'd like to check
Texas out he's like really like you
think you'd like even consider going
here and I was like definitely like
what's like are you kidding me and I was
I was very intrigued because Texas
wasn't really that good at that time
right to be a part of like the rebirth
rebirth or rias ending of Texas he said
he landed you yeah I think it was the
number one class in the nation yep and
then he was like and then we kept it
going and won the national championship
five years later yeah that it started
with that class yeah I do think it
started
with our class a definite I mean it
definitely started with our class they
got me I was a number one recruit we got
Cory reading who was the number one DD
supplier he talked about yep so we had
us two together and a number of other
players but yeah like our problem was
when I was a junior in senior and it was
only max third and fourth year we didn't
have depth on our football team you know
what I mean we didn't have depth when we
had to take out like our top 22 were
amazing but when we had a guy putting
other guys we weren't quite as good when
they got to the Vince young Colt McCoy
era that was our team was rolling I mean
they were rolling like the backups were
gonna be first-round picks just they
just hadn't had their time on the field
and that blows yeah it was cool I mean
he he was a machine recruiting that's
all I got that's mad that's it for Mack
Brown oh good mack brown story for ya so
where are we right now on the money how
we do is we where are we in the money
all right so last week Sims you went
down 220 dollars per week for if I
didn't just what was your big one a
Miami one yeah sorry 220 bleacher bucks
not dollars left go yeah you were you
were very confident in that pick - he
more than 2000 or nothing I thought they
were coming back you are you made $300
last week left go go in the bank
accounts overall Simms you are down 1160
bleacher bucks left go you are in the
negatives as well 490 Blue Sox sued I
got every four o'clock game right except
for the push at Seattle yeah that's
pretty good
good news though GTI guaranteed to lose
Sims you were five and OH last week so
you're up to 13 and 7 on the season left
go to one and one in left goes LOX last
year battle bringing you to 5 10 and 1
you know what's funny is we got into an
argument before about our pushes locks
and I will say this I am I am down to
have our own rankings because I think
some pushes feel like winds and some
pushes feel like losses like when I was
watching the Colts weight so okay guys
when I'm watching the Colts and they're
down by like 20 to the Texans and they
come back and get a push kind of feels
like a win because it should have been a
loss but Seattle who kind of should add
that game against Arizona that felt more
like a loss sometimes you're like oh I
didn't
lose my money and sometimes you're like
man I could have won money this is gonna
be you just justify me every week what
Seattle felt like it should have been a
lot what's what Seattle played down to
their opponent and the cult should have
lost oh my gosh okay movies not that
great to think that they're gonna do
anything against anybody so wait what
did you do in your left go Locke's to
was another one so one so I won two and
one
I am 5 10 and 1/2 and 1 1 2 and 1 you
told to this everybody was the opposite
week you were they picked a go against
you you went one two and one he's right
you know
one two and one no no but I said oh my
gosh he is such a
I am the news to guts and there are
things to uphold no I think this is well
I actually think you're a very good
gambler and I think you're gonna prove
your worth here as the season goes on
it's it's not easy it's yeah this
reverse no I dead serious left goes LOX
is about the whole season you have a
great deal honey you have a great feel
of football and you're left Coe
analytics and then you're you have a big
gut with the trees that hide it a lot
but it's good because the guts good I
don't know what gut has to do with this
BAM I think it's got feeling that he
pies with the I ready to pick some games
this week yes sir
all right so we're starting with
Thursday Night Football - so I'll be
talking I like want to sit up and I like
push the mic with my face dude I still
can't believe you put your face on that
guy's sweat eat it we're starting with
Thursday Night Football here a strangers
sweaty left tight I son I watch do
whatever it required former head former
Colts head coach Josh McDaniels headed
on the road sorry at home against the
Indianapolis Colts you guys didn't even
laugh at my joke I'm sorry
Patriots - ten and a half is the spread
so we broke this down yesterday I gave
all those stats on the Wednesday show
but if you haven't heard it Tom Brady's
never lost on a short week he's six and
oh four and two against the spread luck
has never beaten the Patriots
Owen five one and four against the
spread Patriots is a ten point favorite
or more the last ten times it's
incredible nine and one eight and two
against the spread I just want to say
this that the Colts will be without
their number one receiver their number
one running back their number one tight
end - starting tackles - starting
corners in this Thursday Night Football
game and what's and for the first time
in almost two years
Gronk and Julian Edelman will be on the
field together crazy I texted Josh this
morning I almost put thirteen hundred
and sixty dollars in the Patriots and in
the back of my head I went you know what
it's Thursday crazy things happen and
it's Andrew Luck and you never know they
could be down 20 and he makes it come
back I'm going $200 on the Patriots -
ten and a half okay that's a good one um
I wish you would have done 1,300 stop
being such a wimp I mean just do it
jeez holy cow can you imagine how many
dings okay so yeah I mean you said it
the injury ports scary do we know what
Darius Leonard is he playing which
person Darius Leonard he's their best
defensive player - so he's questionable
yeah all that scary to me with the
Edelman factor plus the Colts can't run
the football and when you're that
one-dimensional that's scary against New
England also New England this offense
okay they played them in the Superbowl
this offensive scheme they got another
look at Philadelphia in the preseason
and now they're getting him again I just
think three cracks at the same office
she's good I'm going $100 on the pen
really yeah just a hundred why didn't
you go more I don't know cuz I'm gonna
win that I'm losing and I just want to
come back that's why it's an interesting
strategy alright guys you know what I
thought about today with my bets right
I thought about blackjack if you have
ever played blackjack ever one blackjack
it's always gets the most money in in
situations where you have the advantage
that's what I feel like I went in black
check so when the dealer has a four or
five or six I'm trying to double all the
time because I want to get my money in
right and what I'm realizing now is in
the beginning of the year I'm gonna go a
hundred all the time I am slowly going
to be making bigger bets this goes on
because I don't want the one that I feel
really confident in New England yeah to
be worth the same as like San Francisco
Arizona I hear you so I'm going to start
just for you I'm gonna start shifting
let you know shifted I know I I'm going
back the other way cuz the only good
week I've had is like being conservative
just trying to get the read at this
point I was really afraid of Miami again
yes moving on to Sunday first game in
the one o'clock slate here the three in
one Tennessee Titans on the road
visiting the Buffalo Bills Chris you'll
go first here spread for this game
Tennessee - three and a half yeah okay
there's so many things did the bill
stink okay there's just no other way
around it right I mean hey the one thing
you can look at it in a positive side
for the Buffalo Bills I mean Shaun
McDermott's a really good defensive
coach and if you have tendencies he can
slow you down from that standpoint but I
think that's about where the positives
ends I mean yeah I like Josh Allen but
there's no help around him and he's not
gonna be able to do everything by
himself
I I think this is an easy one okay I'm
going $100 on the Titans and I'm picking
the game Tennessee I shall go to Buffalo
and slay thy bills I will well Josh
Allen skin as a jacket as I run through
Buffalo's David Buster I need some wings
to be the I'm picking Tennessee don't
forget about the wings
yeah the wings are crucial I know and
especially you one-arm Willie with the
wings over here but I like that one arm
only Tennessee 2714 is how I see this
game playing out
I really think Tennessee will control
the game I don't think it's going to be
pretty but Tennessee's defense is legit
and like Shaun McDermott Dean P's if you
have too many tells his great at
formulating defensive coverages to cover
that so yeah that's right here are the
injuries Micah Hyde wheeze week to week
with a groin injuries big playmaker for
them
Tennessee Kenny Vaccaro is out with a
dislocated elbow his back up Kendrick
Lewis also out rookie Dane quick shank
is in quick shank oi fun one I am
putting $50 on Buffalo plus three and a
half what
we're definitely on drugs last night
here is why I'm wrong mmm danke
here is why I'm wrong everything that
simms just said here is why I'm right
Buffalo is a home dog of three or more
in the last four years four and four
straight up they're pretty good at that
since 2015 Mario does rookie year when
Tennessee is favored on the road they
are two and seven against the spread
they are four and five straight up last
thing in a league where everyone's
throwing for 400 yards
no one has thrown for 300 yards against
Buffalo yet yeah Aaron Rodgers hasn't
thrown for 300 Kirk Cousins hasn't
thrown for 300 Phillip Rivers hasn't
thrown for 300 Joe Flacco hasn't thrown
for 300 however those teams are running
the ball really well guess what
Tennessee is 20 for the NFL and yards
per rush at 3.6 we can only admit Dion
Lewis Derek Henry not great I just hear
your old lines their issue just so you
know with their run game we talked about
in the preseason it's still the issue
yeah I just I look at Buffalo and I've
always believed that early in the year
the 1 o'clock game in Buffalo is super
tricky I think teams kind of start slow
I again thought this for the Chargers I
know I'm on the losing side that's why
I'm only putting $50 I just think that
Tennessee's riding a winning streak
right now and I think maybe they're
gonna get a little comfortable after
like I saw Taylor LaJuan with a flag in
front of the Titans fans last week after
the game like high school game yeah and
they're like in the Eagles fan sections
like give them the middle finger so
they're gonna overlook Buffalo that's
what I'm thinking I just three and a
half is the reason I'm excited I could
see it being a three point Tennessee win
I love that a half point okay
all right guys next game here on the one
o'clock slate the Atlanta Falcons
visiting the Pittsburgh Steelers Falcons
are 1 in 3 Steelers are 1 2 & 1 spread
in this game Pittsburgh - 3 Sims we'll
start with you past 38 Colts 21 I didn't
give a score on that one 38 or so a 17
point where that's where I'm going
okay it's so Atlanta at Pittsburgh
defensive horribleness that's all I can
say Batman I mean it's is this is two
defenses where I just go holy the the
defensive pass coverage is truly abysmal
I mean it's pitiful I've never seen
anything like it both teams both teams
the Falcons
I don't know which ones worse actually
I'm so disappointed in both teams
I think I'm extra disappointed in the
Pittsburgh Steelers least Atlanta has
injuries yes exactly right
Atlanta has injuries as excuse
Pittsburgh I think the other thing that
bothers me about Pittsburgh is like the
one part of them or I felt somewhat
confident was was like oh they're you
know still got some you know big [ __ ]
up front that it can make a mess of a
game they haven't even played well to it
Hayward I mean it's nothing special I
don't see how either one of these teams
fix their defensive issues I think this
is going to be a shootout at the okay
Corral okay and it's just gonna be
whoever has the let ball last I am
putting $100 on the pittsburgh steelers
and i expect them to win what was your
score cuz the the over/under is 58 oh I
picked it 42 to 38 so you have 79 yeah
either one of these defenses to stop
unless they decide to just totally
change their defensive DNA and do crap
they've never done before
yeah 42 plus 38 would be 80 is how you
said 42 and 38 I did injuries Vince
William I believe it might miss this
games William Vince Williams running on
the hamstring he's questionable Devonta
Freeman will be playing Grady Jarrett is
out so they are now missing their best
interior defensive lineman their best
linebacker and both starting safety yeah
aka Jew juice masseuse turns I don't
know do we want to live a good we don't
want to give up Devante this week this
is not the week well no we're playing
Devonta Freeman we're trying to make a
trade I still want to roll with our
fantasy team I think we're gonna be fine
I got the three I don't like making
trades just to make trades what's our
record right now
2 & 2 yes nobody told me that yeah I was
not a great week
I am going to be going $100 on the
Pittsburgh Steelers why am i wrong I'm
wrong because in their last six home
games
Pittsburgh is Owen six against the
spread not great not great here's why
I'm right
Atlanta's never one in Pittsburgh in the
history of the franchise that's always
fun I like that uh since week seven of
2016 so the middle of the really great
year when they went to the Super Bowl
yeah Atlanta against the AFC remember we
just did this last week with Cincinnati
right and I got that one right you did
did you get that right two five and a
half I think you did I'm pretty sure you
did I did Atlanta is one in six straight
up against the AFC Owen seven against
the spread since 2013 since before Dan
Quinn was there there are five and 16
against the spread against the AFC funny
just they're not great against the AFC I
also thought this Pittsburgh offense has
looked spotty but also electric at times
yeah against better defense as Baltimore
on the road right you know and that was
that was at home but whatever Atlanta's
offense I don't think can be playing
better than it has yeah I think that
they've been exceptional against the
Saints they've been exceptional against
the Cincinnati Bengals and all those
games were on the road now it's a one
o'clock game on the those at home on the
road in Pittsburgh I think that this is
the Pittsburgh waking up game we're like
you were all doubting us Mike Tomlin
I love the Steelers after a loss night
we've talked about that before I think
that it's gonna be a shootout and I just
don't see Matt Ryan on the road keeping
up with them I think I think they take a
step back and I think that Pittsburgh
takes a step forward yeah I think
Pittsburgh wins I mean yeah and and like
I I don't I can't believe I'm saying
this but this is game set match for
whoever loses this game it's over
so if Atlanta loses they fall to 1 & 4 1
& 4 and if Pittsburgh loses they fall to
1 3 & 1 1 3 & 1 yeah and you feel
confident that whoever Lew
this game is done I do yes I mean it's
just it's gonna be too much to overcome
especially with both of the divisions
well the reality mmm that's where I just
look at it and go wow they bowled it
let's see the gap with the Ravens would
be pretty strong and the Bengals yeah
and the Bengals are good and the Browns
are not gonna be a pushover this year
there's no there's no guarantee that
they're gonna beat the Browns when they
come up there later in the year anything
with Carolina
right so I mean yeah Tampa Tampa is
gonna match up great with Atlanta you
don't think they're gonna be able to
throw the ball in that defense so that's
where I worry about that yet they're
done whoever loses all right guys next
game on the one o'clock slate here to
and to Denver Broncos coming to MetLife
Stadium to take on the one and three New
York Jets this game opened let go with
the Jets - two and a half the spread we
got it at is Jets -1 so we'll start do
you need to get something here yeah
y'all good I just want to get this ready
uh
I am going spreads jam on your wallet
you're bringing your wallet out I am
going 100 dollars on the Jets - 1 here
is
here is why I'm wrong last three times
Denver's played the Jets there three and
oh and they beat them in Denver last
year 23 to nothing in what was I believe
did Hackenberg come in that game or
Bryce petty what I think you're right I
just remember that the balls it was
definitely Bryce petty and the balls
were going everywhere and Jermaine
Kearse was looking around like what's
going on right now
Jared ville de left the game it's likely
Billy Turner may play tackle for the
Broncos this week yeah here's why I like
this game Denver is different on the
road than they are at home oh they went
battled a battle fist to fist punch to
punch with Kansas City that was at home
they came back against the Raiders at
home they beat the Seahawks at home they
got controlled against the Ravens on the
road and this is not just this season
their last 11 road games they're one in
ten hmm straight up and against the
spring that's scary
there Owen six in their last six 1
o'clock games remember they're Mountain
Time yeah I know it's not here on the
East Coast right so they're 1 o'clock on
a Sunday after playing Monday night
battling it out against mahomes how
tired were they on even bring a quote to
my pick Chris Harris on chasing mahomes
extra that was the worst I've ever felt
I had a full body cramp I had to get to
IVs and I was still cramping in my feet
in the fourth quarter I was fighting
through it I pride myself in being in
great shape this game I couldn't I was
just done ok yeah so that's a corner
that's a Tuesday morning right and they
have to go on a short week to play the
Jets right I'm putting $100 on the Jets
minus one okay seems before you give
your breakdown Bryce petty in last
year's game against the Broncos 2 of 9
for 14 yards whoa he came in and there
was a third and 5 in that game or a
fourth and five where Jermaine Kearse
had an out route and Bryce petty threw
it over his head and curse went and just
watched it seems your breakdown out here
I come all the teams okay alright so
rush yeah this is a tricky game to me
okay it really is a tricky game and I if
I was really
gambling real money here I would not
gamble on this football game I do like
this Denver Broncos defense I think
they're gonna give Sam Darnall all he
can handle
so that's that's one thing that concerns
me on the jet side of the football the
points you made about it being a short
week losing a big loss like that
having do yes play plays that went on
forever cuz mahomes was scrambling all
that does that's a real thing it's gonna
wear that defense out um Todd polls in
that defense I don't know what to think
of the Todd Bowles and that defense
right now they're a little bit hit or
miss for me at times they've had some
weeks where I look at the gameplan and
go man they're all over things and then
I look at last week and go man I could
have told you some of the place
Jacksonville was gonna run and thus it
like you know shall the whole thing
we've always talked about and I go I
don't understand how teams don't figure
yeah I mean and some do like the week
before the Titans did and that's why
they held them to six points and I want
to go what didn't you watch that game
and realize that they didn't let screens
and boots and shallow crosses beat them
like I don't I just don't get that so
III I'm in between there I think at the
end of the day I'm just gonna go with
the team and the Broncos okay I'm
putting $100 on the Broncos I'm just
going with the quarterback I trust a
little bit more in this I don't know
what to think of Sam Donald in the
offense right now Donald's had some good
moments certainly but had some really
scary moments well $40 $20 on Monday you
walked by and I said I kind of like the
Jets you said I'll put money on it
I'm putting money okay I'll take it and
then if you win it I'll give it back to
you no that's not how this works we give
it to Josh okay I'll hold it I won't
spend it this weekend don't gear for $20
sure okay deal so we're at money it's a
minus one so I'm not even gonna like are
you cool with not getting the point well
just to it pick them or do you want the
point I mean you wanna do this front all
these people you wanna take the point
yeah there's a gambling show yeah okay
what's the point
Wow now you know now you know how Sims
is wire yeah so I'm holding your twenty
and we're just going to assume where's
where's your rubber band then you hold
it right there it's right here my hair
my hair band and everything is right
here
all right well come on show no it's not
giving up my mind you spend this later
you don't know what
no I look I'm not that confident in this
game no it is a good boy a coin flip
yes and it's really gonna you're right
it's gonna be down to who protects the
ball and makes plays more yeah Sam
Bradford and Case Keenum and Radford is
not in this one but it's darn already.i
I was making 23 17 Broncos right but I
could see it being like I really went
like it could be 17 16 I have one
conversation yeah I'm I'm seeing a lot
of people calling for Todd Bowles head a
lot of people that are big Jets fans
that I know are done with tunnels
I had joked and I'm pretty sure I called
for Todd Bowles to be fired last year
because I've never seen him talk on the
sidelines yeah right he's the only coach
like here I see Andy Reid on the bench
with Benjamin Holmes and then Todd
Bowles is just you know he's just yeah
the whole game yes and and it's it i you
know if he starts off one in four you
know is he the first coach that's gonna
be fired you think I think it's gonna be
yeah he's gonna be in the conversation
yeah he I mean yeah he could be in that
conversation solitary one in four is it
fair Jets fans be annoyed and go I don't
know if this guy's think I think they're
going a little hard just a little early
I don't I would like to like wait two or
three more weeks before we go on that
but I understand their frustration like
games like last week where you just go I
don't know what the game plan was I
think the other thing too that they
played hard it exacerbates it more right
when I'm watching an NFL that likes to
go like Andy Reid right for fourth and
one on his own 34 in the first quarter I
and now you have Todd Bowles who's like
we're down 19 let's kick a ha all right
let's get a field goal on fourth and
goal right like he's the opposite of
where the league's going yeah and so as
a Jets fan it makes me even I'm not I'm
saying if I was a Jets fan yeah it
wouldn't make me even more exacerbated
because I'm going damn we're not winning
and we're playing not to lose when
everyone else is going for yeah great I
I agree it's it's very frustrating and I
think it's going down that
if they don't correct some things here
really soon all right guys next game
here on the one o'clock slate and this
is a big one so let's take our time with
this one the three-in-one Jacksonville
Jaguars on the road visiting the Kansas
City Chiefs at 4:00 no left go I know
you're a big weather watcher this year I
want to let you know rain is in the
forecast so keep that in mind game is in
Kansas City we got rain before Castle
you both know I no longer look at the
weather report oh you're done with the
weather yeah Hurricane Harry over here
for three weeks
well well he got he got burned by like
seven games and week one was like I was
like it's supposed to rain hurricanes
coming and then I just thought how many
times have you ever had like a wedding
on a Saturday yeah you look at Tuesday
and it's like it's gonna rain right and
then Saturday comes perfect yeah I'm
just done yeah spread for this game
Chiefs minus three left go we'll come to
you first for net is out yeah Brandon
lender and nor well did not practice
Wednesday they're both questionable okay
Linder in addition to his injuries is
also having back spasms which is
interesting okay my prior to Kansas City
is reportedly confident that Sammy
Watkins and D Ford will play on Sunday
they need that you talked about how big
D Ford and Sammy Watkins both are yeah
my bet I am taking Jacksonville for $100
plus three thanks again
which part sometimes I talk and they
don't even the words I know this is a
good day like we're we're seen it happen
here's the reason I'm wrong their last
five games at home Kansas City is for
one straight up and against the spread
Wow also in their last three games
against the Chiefs Jacksonville's oh and
three but we all know that those are
those old other teams last year in 2017
Jacksonville was an underdog of three or
more three times they were three and oh
and three now against the Sprint
I like Jacksonville when they're an
underdog
I am afraid of Jacksonville when they're
favored by a lot of points I look at
this game similar reason look I believe
that I'm actually picking against every
team that was an overtime last week and
and I some of its on purpose like I was
50/50 I went with the team that wasn't
in overtime last week but this one I'm
going it's a short week and Kansas City
just faced the best defense they faced
this year in Denver right and it took
everything like not only everything you
have to realize in my mind this is what
I thought when Patrick mahomes has an
historic performance where we look at
each other and say wow I think only him
and Aaron Rodgers could have won that
game yes and then they're gonna play
Jacksonville like how much better can
Patrick mahomes play and so I don't
think that the creme hunt running is
gonna be as easy as it was last week
like he could like he overpowered people
he put the crown of his helmet into the
chest of a guy and took him back that's
not happening against Jacksonville so I
think I don't think it's interesting I
don't think Kansas City has faced a
defense that's good I don't know if
Jacksonville's faced an offense this
good sure but they did face a schemer
and Kyle Shanahan and he was able to
mizu my teams and thinking about Kansas
City yeah but I think when it comes to
the the crazy force and the immovable
object I think that it's harder to
adjust for Jacksonville's defense than
it is to adjust for Patrick mahomes I'm
going Jacksonville yeah I hear you on
all that I really do and yeah I mean hey
I think I know what you're gonna say
like shanahan scheme Jacksonville last
year bub McVeigh didn't I mean Jared
Goff threw for 95 yards yeah maybe you
know what I mean so all right so I also
there's so many things to hit on Kansas
City's drawl ups are a lot more simple
yeah it's Annie Reid's a great play
calling yeah but it's a lot of like some
option stuff it's like once in a while
whereas like the Rams and the Niners
it's going to be read yes you're right
to emphasize your point there Andy
Reid's a great window dressing guy the
schemes not necessarily like whoa what
is it they're trying to do it really sip
what it's the triple motion be
for the snap to wear now you have the
linebacker going wait hold on the rules
were this and now I can't remember what
the rules were
and then he did quadruple I know so
that's the window dressing he's amazing
at making a normal play look very
different and confusing linebackers and
safeties in that manner would you look
at him for elected shut up but so I do
think if Kansas City wants to win this
football game they're going to have to
run the ball and run it to just run it
like they're gonna be like okay we only
got two yards but it's going to pay off
you have to stay after the run with
Jacksonville if you get into this and
that's so hard to do I know especially
with Patrick Mahalo I know it's really
do you really want to be in a close game
with Jackson fine I know but I don't I
don't I think it's gonna be a close game
no matter what so they need to play for
the end game at the end of the day and
if there's one weakness the
Jacksonville's defense it is their run
defense because we talked about this
last year you know they put eight guys
at the line of scrimmage and you go all
they're stopping the run but they do
stunts that really are to stop the pass
and so they scare you with the people at
the line of scrimmage
going eight and go oh man there's eight
we got to throw the ball but they're
really playing pass coverage behind it
and they're ready for about and they're
stunting their line to get to the
quarterback so okay there's that you
talked about the Denver factor right I
played against some of these defenses in
my day right where there was the
Baltimore Ravens and I'm not trying to
say I'm gonna say one defense get you up
to speed for the next defense well it
can but Denver can call themselves a
good defense all they want they ain't
the Jacksonville Jaguars Jacksonville is
one of those teams where you'll watch on
film all week and you're like man that
quarter I could have hit that guy why
didn't he do it you know why because
when you get out there on the field and
you go holy [ __ ] coleus Campbell is
everywhere and Yannick and Gok ways
everywhere and Jalen Ramsey's really
fast and AJ booyah and miles Jack and
all of a sudden the quarterback can't
see the field clearly because he's like
what the [ __ ] there's super freaks all
over the field and I'm missing [ __ ] that
I don't normally miss because they're
just bigger and faster than the rest of
football that's where I worry about
and I really think the end of the day
she's like that I went off like that
that's good but the the the other thing
that I look at is I mean Jacksonville's
offense is no slouch in Kansas City's
defense sucks and Eric Berry is
officially out damn so that hurts and I
do think even though a for net not
believin everybody's sitting upright
yeah I would imagine he's not gonna play
this week and I just think with
Jacksonville's offense their run game I
think they will be able to control the
clock the offensive line issues are
certainly something to watch as we go on
later here in the weakest Linder's one
of the best centers in football and
Norwell might be the best guard at the
end of the day I just think that
Jacksonville is too much for the Chiefs
for both on Jackson yeah I'm going $100
on the Jags I think this will be just a
learning experience or in my homes yeah
he thinks he got away with some of those
plays last week against Denver you know
he ain't gonna get away with him against
this group I just don't see it happening
I think the Jaguars win this game
outright 24 to 20 in Arrowhead and
established themselves as clearly the
second best team in football behind the
Rams so what I always think to with my
LOX is whichever game I pick first is
the game that I get the most online
grief for because it's the first one
that pops so people don't stand for the
end of the video that's the internet
yeah could you imagine if I make that
like the first one I mean it's kind of a
bowl i I can't want to say I'm just I am
surprised like Kansas City's a
three-point spread I just I I guess I'm
surprised I am a little bit what would
you have made it I would have probably
favored Jacksonville by 1 1/2 I do I
think they go back and they go ok well
they were there one road game they lost
to the Titans yeah 9 to 6 maybe it's a
road thing border at home I think it's
the Titans Jays crazy I know the one was
the road game they went to the Giants
and one there oh yeah they beat the
Patriots at home and they won last week
against the Jets this opened at 3 and
hasn't moved hasn't moved
all right know where the late money oh
god I think this one's gonna move late
I think Mont big money daddy roar Bucs
are gonna go Daddy Warbucks I should say
you know that's probably go on
Jacksonville yeah do you know that's
where I'm gonna go bucks a knee
tomorrow speaking of money changing I
switched my bet on this next guy this
morning next game here guys the two to
one and one Green Bay Packers on the
road visiting the one in three Detroit
Lions left go
they are playing indoors it's gonna be
mostly cloudy outside though I don't
know if that affects how you feel the
team is gonna be without the Sun a lot
of jokes today guys I like six seconds
that Aaron Rodgers will spend from the
bus to unders not gonna see the Sun it's
gonna be interesting yeah that affects
mood well yeah you know what you know
else didn't see the Sun who's that Andy
oh good transition there Thank You Green
Bay Detroit
TJ Lange concussion protocols v one of
his career now yeah I'm worried if I
spread is Green Bay minus one I didn't
say that oh man that's really it's scary
I didn't really I would have loved in
the play against his former team Blount
did not practice on Wednesday be a good
thing I sent in my pics this morning
that I would take Green Bay minus 100
and I switched it the old switcheroo and
putting a hundred dollars on Detroit
plus one at home this is where you're at
a yeah you're at a competitive advantage
here because this half of the table does
not get alerts so all right I'll tell
you the information that caused me to
switch I was fifty fifty and then I saw
today that Randall Cobb geronimo Allyson
and Davante Adams all miss practice yes
I know I knew that so that's okay yeah I
was just back and forth yeah here's why
I'm wrong right last ten games with
Rodgers versus Detroit not including
last year and all that Packers rating to
against the spread and straight up so
like that should be enough to scare me
yeah last 15 games for Detroit as a home
underdog they're five and ten they're
six and nine against the spread and they
beat New England in the same situation
two weeks ago yeah I'm going Detroit
because even though they lost that game
to Dallas last week I like the way that
the offense was looking I kind of did I
liked the way Stafford even in the
clutch which he's always good at those
receivers Golden Tate making guys miss
and I'm
hoping that they listen to care to you
about carrion Johnson yeah and he gets
more of their may be blunt helps it but
I'm just kind of thinking that the home
team wins here and and that's really as
simple as it came down to me it's the
home team and I'm getting a point and I
just kind of what with that like I'm
just gonna be realized sometimes that's
all there is to it I know I don't know
what to say yeah you know I don't got
any magic formula I mean this came as
scary I mean I'm just saying if I had
real money I would never bet this gay
never never this is it is either side
makes a lot of sense I think I look at
it like this I look at the the thing
that scares me the Lions defense man can
you run on them well they're playing the
team that really can't run I mean Rogers
was the second leading rusher last week
again with the pogos to ever like very
excited about Aaron Jones right now yeah
okay it's it's it's good but they're
like Green Bay is like haven't seen
running backs in five years I mean it's
like yeah it's they see like a cup of
water and it's an exactly right it's
just they've never even had it they
haven't had a talented running back up
there since I'm on green I was gonna say
among I mean it really is it's like
unbelievable so I look at that and go
okay they can't take advantage that with
the Detroit Lions defense now Detroit
also their past events is phenomenal to
this point but it's also phenomenal
because everybody runs the ball on them
so they just go we'll keep running on
them and see where it goes from there uh
the wide receivers thing scares me I
think Devante and Geronimo we're gonna
make it I don't know about Randall Cobb
Randall Cobb doesn't seem great the only
reason I'm more afraid of Geronimo is
he's in concussion protocol it could not
be so then again those would be things
to watch for going forward
now you get to the Lions you know the
Lions the offense did look better last
week right I agree with you there I
still have moments of being concerned
with it as a whole I think really at the
end of the day the big decider for me
was this that there's not a great pass
rush in Detroit and when number 12 has
time I don't give a damn how good your
coaches route combinations are and thing
like that I just think he'll be able to
pull magic off I think this games 2220
and Rogers gets the ball with a minute
30 left and they win them with a field
goal I'm going Packers I'm going a
hundred on the Packers I think they win
the game twenty three twenty over the
Lions the other reason I want Detroit is
I realized I've bet on the Packers every
game this year
yeah I've realized that my argument for
him has always been at Aaron Rodgers
right I was like I just I'm not gonna do
it this week
all right guys next game one o'clock
here how much did you did 100 hundred
yeah the three and one Baltimore Ravens
on the road visiting the Cleveland
Browns one two and one
spread in this game is Baltimore - three
Sims we'll start with you okay hold on
one second I lost where I was okay
alright Baltimore Cleveland
Baltimore's old line is a force to be
reckoned with Cleveland's defense is not
as good as I thought it was going to be
overall coverage wise what's that after
that one Oakland game you know I just I
think it's I I worry about their
coverage in the back end a little bit I
do
III think Denzel Ward has shown to be
very good I'm certainly better than I
expected him to be but the other cover
corners and their other starting corner
Terrence Mitchell because for exactly
right so so that's scary to me okay Greg
Williams is creative but sometimes
creative to a detriment I want to say
just because he takes too many chances
could do too many crazy blitzes whatever
it may be I mean the Browns defense I'm
sitting here looking at it is 25th and
football Wow okay the Ravens can run the
ball and they can throw the ball now I
don't know what their stats are on the
offensive side of the ball but I know
it's a force and I'm usually right with
that kind of stuff I don't think they're
gonna be able to overly pressure Joe
Flacco I would be shocked if they do I
know Myles Gary might get a hit here and
there or whatever but I don't think
they're gonna be able to ruin the game
with their pressure the other side of
the ball
man I like Baker and Baker was
phenomenal last week I'm a diffused
rookie mistakes whatever else but man
there was a lot more good than bad
Jimmy Smith back the Ravens defense
is the best he has seen and it's gonna
be a lot more complicated than watching
the Raiders play the Browns last week
like when it's there another team when
he gets out where the Ravens he's gonna
go first so he's gonna walk to the line
of scrimmage the first time ago whoa
they're big I realize I have to worry
about Maurice Hurst right in college
last exactly right and Bruce Irvin the
Brandon Williams be like by the way six
three three ten I could do is right in
the back and like 350 actually that's
what's crazy and then yeah it's guys
like Pierce who are also three fifth and
then their subs butte on and brett urban
and CJ Mosley sorry I'm sorry I'm going
too long here I'm going a hundred
dollars on the Ravens I do think this
will be a close football game but in the
end the Ravens like to take brown paper
bags I don't know what I'm going with
that but I'm picking the Ravens 24 to 20
laughs no your breakdown uh Hayden
Hearst could make his first start for
the Ravens for Cleveland Landry and
Callaway other two top two wide
receivers have been missing practice
this week both with knee issues I
mentioned Terrence Mitchell before I am
putting 180 dollars on the Baltimore
Ravens
that's not your raven voice that's
Smeagol yeah come on the character
please Jimmy Smith is back yeah I don't
have a reason why I'm wrong which makes
me a little bit nervous because all of
my stats are for the Ravens since John
Harbaugh has gotten to Baltimore so this
is the year I graduated college 2008 a
decade ago against the Browns he's 18
and - yeah against the spread he's 14
and 6 and he's currently on a five-game
winning streak
the Browns after a loss under Hugh
Jackson are 7 and 23 against the spread
worst mark in the NFL in the last two
years
obviously they went Oh in 16 yes missus
a Cleveland team against a crappy
defense that went to overtime in the
West Coast
is now coming back and play like a full
overtime we're Baker's sitting there
being like man ithe humble to balls and
I'm in my own head right now and like
man this other guy came down through it
and overtime I couldn't even get a
single Drive going at all and here's
Baltimore that like think about if
Baltimore Baltimore s put up 47 23 27 26
what is Baltimore scored like that right
now the one game that they kind of
looked bad at the second half they
dominated against Cincinnati since an 18
that's 3 & 1
right so they dominated the Steelers
they dominated the Broncos they came
back and almost beat the Bengals and
dominated the bills yeah and now we're
gonna question that they're a three
point favorite in Cleveland yeah
with Justin Tucker like so all of the
field goals are good yeah I'm taking
Baltimore and I'm left go locking and
locking it like that's not even love it
like you think they're gonna win like by
10 something like that your exam yeah I
could see that
all right guys next game here on the
schedule the Giants won your your
analysis only made me more confident
about Baker seeing a team that he's
never seen before like he saw a few
drives of the Jets and and they the Jets
openly came out and said we had nothing
prepared for Baker and then he played
the Raiders and yeah they put up 42 but
like one of them was a defensive
touchdown I think there might have been
a special teams touchdown there too one
of them was like a Nick Chubb 70 yard
run yeah there was a me Nick shot about
three carries for 103 yards the other
one was a 50-yard Nick job yes sir then
would acre fumble twice like and now
you're facing the Ravens yeah welcome
right Nick Chubb is not running for a
seventy yards no no he's not the one on
three New York Giants headed down on the
road to visit the two-in-one Carolina
Panthers coming off their bye and guys
it is gonna be hot six degrees partly
cloudy so the Sun won't be beating down
on the field about 86 degrees that could
be hot Sims thanks Sam that's gonna
affect them thanks Sam it's gonna be
better for the southern team which is
the Carolina all right that's all we
need who's your pick left go we'll go
over to you know who Sam champion is
right now I don't what's happening is
the weather guy for ABC you know I know
you grew up in this area and you don't
know New York local news I know he was
also does a lot of national
are we going with the broadcasting
conversation no I'm actually breakdown
is that you didn't know who Sam champion
yeah I met Sam champion an event in
Louisville tell us about its that's he
was like hello I'm Sam champion and then
I left I was like definitely not his
name or Israel right well we guess that
remember we had storm fields here in New
York - they're all fake no no that's a
real because his dad was also a
weatherman storm fields and he named his
kid storm like I think field Yates is a
fake name - it's my doppelganger that's
your doppelganger gangers what's your
pick Ali Hashi she got separated from
your family and somehow went to the
Middle East and yours went the Jewish
route and on trees you should compare
you're 21
I don't know we should find out I don't
know I use the hat with the chic thing
though is really cool all right
Giants Carolina here we go that's all it
did okay now would probably be like
that's racist it would be I know you
can't do that okay
Giants Panthers both two good defenses
okay I look at the Giants and go hey
there's some things there that I
certainly like but they have a weakness
to their defense and it is their run
defense and Carolina has a weakness to
their offense and that would be their
pass protection
well the Giants can't rush the passer
and the Panthers can run the ball and
the Giants aren't great at stopping the
run that scares me a little bit I also
am scared that Carolina had the week off
I don't think that's a good thing
anymore I'm pretty sold on that I do
think they could sleepwalk a little here
early on but either way I do think
they're gonna have some wrinkles I've
been totally encouraged by north turner
and what he's done with this offense
I would think over this week off that
they have incorporated DJ more into this
offense because he's really their only
guy that can do things off the charts or
when things break down out of the wide
receiving corps they're gonna use
McCaffrey I like all that is a Liddy a
Vernon gonna play ever
I don't know question I know so then I
flip it over to the other side and I go
okay the Panthers their defense it's
very sound they actually have some
really good cover corners this year they
did they have a weakness it is there a
run defense but the
don't run the ball and I don't trust
them to be effective doing it say Quan
he might make a Superman type play where
we go whoa it was a nice play but I
think the other estimate will be a bunch
of crap
Carolina's defensive front is pretty
damn good
and I think they can infiltrate
especially the interior part of the old
line with the k1 shorts and all eyes
favorite spot to Avery
up in his face so I think when I look at
it from that aspect I do think this is
going to be a close game because I think
this is like desperate do-or-die New
York Giants right here they're they're
on the verge of me saying this season's
over if they don't win this football
game
but they're still gonna lose and I'm
going to pick the I picked putting $100
on the Giants up I think they're gonna
keep it let's go Goliath I don't think
they win this game of course I'm picking
the Panthers to win
22:17 I just don't think the pass rush
is quite good enough to totally start
scared me me Eli so you think that the
Saints have a better pass rush to the
Panthers the Saints pass rusher wasn't
that we've already discussed this that
wasn't that great last week I mean yes
oh no I know I'm saying I don't think
they're gonna ruin the game I think that
they'll he'll have a few more moments
yeah I guess what do you what are you
asking me there
well what I'm asking is I don't even
think the pass rush has to be that good
I don't think you need your want to
scare you're exactly right your guy
think that if Don Terry Puhl gets in
there you're like ah [ __ ] your and I
would say the interior part of the
Carolina Panthers d-line is better than
the Saints which they'll be back there
even more especially against those guys
so for left go gives his pick 22:17
Panthers win the football game $100 a
Giants sake I just want to say I'm proud
of you for working eli meme into your
coverage this week I've noticed it you
used it several times thank you and it's
been really good I'm really connected to
the Internet thank you returning the
Giants are hopeful that Vernon and Eli
Apple return I don't know if that's
gonna happen Josh Moro is back for the
Giants okay is that a big deal
defensive lineman he is he's a he was
Becher's guy in
zona he's a little bit how would I
explain him you know he's at that big
five technique three four type of guy
like a frets the edge can set the edge
can to Gabba tackle like almost like a
Bret Urban in yeah Bren determine your
right and in Baltimore but yeah he's a
guy that can do a little bit of
everything on the defensive front uh
Caroline whoa big coughs he's big
coughing whoa yeah I got something too
much oh man I am putting $100 on the
Carolina Panthers here's why I'm wrong
yeah that's like Penn State uh it's
Alaska the last ten games of being a
seven plus dog the Giants are six three
and one against the spread they're good
when you doubt them just like we did a
few weeks ago with Houston here's why I
love the Panthers yeah I thought about
your bye week thing right in the last
three years after the bye Carolina's
three and oh and three and now against
the spread Ron Rivera has them focused
also Ron Rivera as a favorite of seven
or more since 2011 they're 12 and oh
nine two and one against the spread I
circled this and then I unn circled it
as a left go lock because I think you
are right about the Giants being
completely back against the wall and I
feel like they were that way against
Houston and they came out much better in
the first half I'm very confident that
Carolina wins this game I'm confident
they cover the spread
mmm I am good but I don't know if I'm
left go a lot confident my only thing
would be I really wish they had Thomas
Davis back for this he comes back next
week because they had the buy it delayed
that one more week
but it's Eli on the road is there any
chance that Eli is better on the road
than he is at home like the Carolina
deep you can feel the pressure at home
sometimes more than you think and the
deed and on the road as a quarterback
it's us against the world because Eli
just did that in Houston I know the
thing with this game is if if the Giants
jump out to a lead they could absolutely
cover the spread right cuz just Cam
Newton is
is the momentum guy yeah but yeah I feel
a little bit less confident there's just
something about you saying back against
the wall
with those guys that it just that scares
me desperate teams always or make me
think right like I went back and I was
like oh Atlanta Pittsburgh I was like
but they're both destiny art and their
desperation crosses it out right it is
all right guys last game on the one
o'clock here the three-in-one Miami
Dolphins on the road visiting the
Cincinnati Bengals conditions in
Cincinnati going to be Miami like 87
degrees partly cloudy is it October or
what it is October warming it's not real
it's a made-up myth yeah totally fake 87
degrees in Cincinnati left goal start
with crap Rashad Jones ready to go for
Miami
uh Josh sitting and Kilgore remember
their starting left guard and the
starting center are out with injuries
there is a little development of an
injury thing right now that's
interesting with Devante Parker oh we
have been saying for a long time i look
i love Devante Parker but in the NFL
he's missed a ton of games on and it
came out that I think Tannehill and GaSe
both came out this week he was a
surprise scratch last week and
apparently a lot of Miami's game plans
were to feature Devante Parker against
the Patriots and when he went out they
were both like we were not he wasn't
even on the injury report and he was out
and so I don't know what's going on with
the finger thing right what is the
feeling was I don't know but I grew up I
covered Devante Parker in high school so
I don't really wanna say anything bad
but I think that should be enough Mixon
is expected back for the Bengals
Giovanni did not practice on Wednesday
vantes Burfict is back how back is he
marvin lewis was asked is he in good
shape and is he excited to be back with
the team while marvin lewis said that he
was standing there and someone came up
behind him and picked him off the ground
and he said it's only one person it's
perfect
he's back I am putting $150 on the
Bengals - six and a half
I really want to be confident here's the
reason I'm right
Miami their last seven Road games one in
six straight up and against the spread
the only win was that Jets game where
they weren't even the best team on the
field that day according to Chris Simms
but the other five they Tannehill wasn't
playing right
other than the paper at one very good
point after a loss under gase they are
the second worst against the spread mark
in the NFL brenston dude only the Browns
were worse for ten and one against the
spread after a loss Cincinnati their
last 10 October home games 801 - hmm and
there's six three and one against the
spread and also since 2011 Dalton's
rookie year as a favorite of five or
more the Bengals are twenty three four
and one
I definitely think the Bengals do this I
just worry after you came away this is a
Sims reaction here about you weren't
that impressed with the Bengals and
their offense and it was more the
Atlanta defense and I don't know what
the Miami Dolphins are right now Yeah
right they are a mystery I think that
they're a well coached team I think they
have a lot of good pieces but they have
injuries on their offensive line and
defensive line and there they got
embarrassed so you know they're gonna
come out hard I'm only going $50.00
because I'm just not sure and
six-and-a-half is a lot but I could to
also see the Bengals win this game by 21
because of the injuries and Jordan
Phillips apparently beings yeah somehow
are being mad either way yeah yeah this
is interesting there's there's some you
know caught coaching cross over here
like Matt Burke the new deke the D
coordinator for the Miami Dolphins he's
from Cincinnati
so he's from there the Dolphins are I
mean I want to say the Bengals offense
is gonna have a good feel for what the
Dolphins want to do on the defensive
side of the ball the Dolphins defense is
still good I'm not going to back down
from the Dolphins defense they did some
good things in that game last week they
just got on the field too much again I
know I said this on our Tuesday podcast
but you know the game was three to
nothing with 12 minutes left in the
second quarter and then it was a pick
play
for a touchdown granite it was ten
nothing and then mr. Ryan Tannehill
fumble
so fumble score again seventeen nothing
and that was a wrap the game was over so
I still there's things I like about the
Miami Dolphins defense is basically what
I'm saying I know the injuries are
concerning I haven't been necessarily
blown away with the Bengals defense now
you know Terrell Austin's there I think
they're learning a new scheme i-i-i-i
this is a tough game for me to bet it is
it really is you know I look at
sometimes the chances that Cincinnati
plays when they do go man-to-man and all
that and we've talked about like the
bang the the Miami Dolphins have some
receivers that can beat that type of
type of coverage I got to think Adam
GaSe and company realized that their
game plan lacked to a degree last week
and they have to do more if they want to
win this type of football game both of
these defenses led up points and led up
to many yards altogether the Bengals are
letting up 28 points per game they're
three and one but I could sit here and
make a case that they were very close to
being one in three I mean they really
had the only game that they just flat
out one was the Ravens right week one I
mean looked like Andrew Luck was going
down the field to score a touchdown to
win and Jack Doyle fumbled right you
know last week that game could have gone
either way - it was extremely close
they're just whoever had the ball last
last week that's all it was so I don't
know how to feel about this I personally
would not bet money on this game and I
am going to go a hundred dollars on the
fins just because I think six-and-a-half
is too much for my legs I get it a
little too much and I'm picking them
totally and again it's it's a your bet
is a great bet for this reason this
reason only it's the perfect storm of
everyone suddenly high on Cincinnati
yeah three and one they do ride on
national stage and the Dolphins went up
there in their big thing and blew it
yeah it's a you you made a true better
spec today
failed to do thank you who did you pick
to win the game I'm going to pick the
Bengals to win the game 28 to 27 I'd
like to switch my bet to Miami I can
turn
anything else we need to say about that
game we're good all right guys
next game here moving on to the
afternoon the four clocks the one in
three Oakland Raiders taking on the LA
chargers who are 2 & 2 in Los Angeles
only 71 degrees in Los Angeles on Sunday
so gonna be a nice cool fall day their
spread in this game is Los Angeles
chargers minus five and a half Sims
we'll start with you nobody seems to be
concerned with this stuff I don't know I
feel like I look around my town
sometimes I'm like there's anybody
worried that it's 85 and it's October
and everyone's like no it's great I love
it okay I don't know I played football
growing up it was cool this time of the
year I think I'm gonna make the
temperatures a staple of my leg up it
gives me a global warming jump off I
like it perfect alright seems you're up
first Chargers -5 and a half okay
holy defense's have you seen neither one
of these they don't play they don't play
it's unreal and it's the perfect example
of my rant this week it's the Zimmer
scheme versus Seattle scheme oh no whoa
three deep and we just get torched all
the time but we just were sound and we
know what we're gonna do oh great
everybody else knows what you're gonna
do - and it's horrible both teams
letting up 30 points per game what
that's like insanity
Derwin James has been coming along oh my
god he's before it everywhere Cory Lou
gets back Duren James is playing so well
that Jon Gruden said that he wanted to
draft him but unfortunately they took a
safety in Carl Joseph two years ago in
the first round and Obi melon fonville
in the second round aka I wanted Derwin
James but Reggie Jack Reggie Reggie
Mackenzie Mackenzie wouldn't let me yeah
yeah he's been very good he really has
he's really come along because in the
preseason it was not spectacular like in
the preseason I was said whoa the
Dolphins got the better safety they got
Minka they got but now I would go it's
very close and Minka's really being more
use as a Nickelback anyways but Derwin
is very good there's no doubt about that
I think this is it I'm just gonna make
this plain and simple
the Raiders defense stinks the Chargers
defense stinks the both offenses are
very
good I do think that the Chargers
offense is better and more well-rounded
but I think the thing that scares me
more than anything at the end of the day
is the Raiders run defense that's where
I go what they're letting up a hundred
and thirty nine yards per game and
rushing defense and I think you could
make the argument that other than Todd
Gurley Melvin's Melvin Gordon there I
don't think anyone's running better like
Alvin Kamara is a little bit of receiver
in sequence moments but moments - every
time you're right and like Gordon it's
what he did the San Francisco legend he
had a few like all-time highlight reel
runs your eyes those are like runs that
yes the stats don't quantify it no
because he did more than was it was
there to be taken like yeah like it was
a 10-yard run and he broke four tackles
and then ran for another 40 yards that's
what I mean by greatness
Lenny pickin okay sorry keep me on track
I am going a hundred dollars on the
Raiders okay
just because five and a half was a
little too much for me
Jasmine baby but you're gonna lose sorry
you ain't gonna win the game you just
covering the spread baby sorry Russell o
Kuhn will be 38:34 charge chargers
Russell o Kuhn will be a game time
decision Corey Legion is back and I hope
that he has a big impact I am going $10
on the Chargers I don't want to touch
this game I think that Chargers I saw a
stat online at the unn
[Music]
so I read some center get spitting value
underdog team that was on camera 15 to 3
in the last 18 meetings but like I don't
know if that's actually true like I what
was it the underdog 50 was 15 and 3 in
the last 18 meetings I went back and I
was like I can't find these lines and I
don't know if this is true like I don't
believe you
I'm picking the Chargers but I'm not
that confident if the reason I'm
confident is the readers last five games
on the road against the team in the AFC
West or Owen five one and four against
the spread since 2012 when the Chargers
are favored by six or more and this has
obviously dropped down they're 17 and OH
10 and 7 against the spread but what
scares me is in their last 14 games
against the team with a losing record
the Chargers are 4 and 10 against the
spread I do not like betting on the
Chargers I don't
I bet against them last week with the
Niners I won that one that was a big one
you lost that one because I don't the
Chargers are a team that let bad teams
hang with them and they they let good
teams get ahead and then try and shoot
out like they almost did with the Rams
which was closer than that one appeared
I don't I don't trust the Chargers I
think that it goes back to everything
I've said they don't use analytics I
don't really think their offensive plan
is there I think Phillip Rivers goes out
there and does whatever he wants to do
I don't trust their kicker and and their
defenses is anemic so I don't trust it
but I look at the Raiders and guess what
Raiders were in overtime last week and
either they're gonna be tired and so I'm
taking the Chargers $10 ok
I get you alright guys next game here
425 Eastern oh and for Arizona Cardinals
on the road visiting the 1 and 3 7 Cisco
49ers come on 49ers spreading this game
San Francisco - 4 and I will start this
off with left go by reminding everyone
of a quote from last Sunday Adam left go
quote I [ __ ] love betting on the CJ
Beathard led 49ers your right hand quote
and I'm gonna add something to that
quote hit me
I [ __ ] love betting on the CJ
Beathard 49ers when they're an underdog
I am betting $10 on Arizona Plus for Joe
Staley oh it's so cute like a little
cover like a 4-point cover joe staley
mike McGlinchey weston Richburg none of
them practice on Wednesday all a little
bit banged up Staley was really banged
up but he's tough and he usually plays
through Richard Sherman Marquis Goodwin
who the heck knows last six games
against San Francisco Arizona is six and
oh I am are they really three and three
against the spread but then again it's a
lot of Bruce Arians
yeah I don't really want to count that
but yeah hold on the 49ers lost to the
Cardinals twice last year no check it
right now yes so I got you laughs go
keep going they beat the Niners 1815 in
the beginning of the year we before and
then right after the bye they beat
Arizona 20 to 10 they beat Famers go in
San Francisco 20 to 10 I forgot about
that 106 and oh yeah and the last 10
games that the Niners were a favorite
there 109 against the spread I'm taking
the points um I was impressed with CJ
Beathard last week I was also impressed
with Josh Rosen and I think that I think
the the excitement about Josh Rosen does
Rosen does more for the Arizona
Cardinals and the excitement about
better does for the Niner I would agree
with that
the real thing the Niners know their
season is done and they know what CJ
Beathard is and they're coming off a
game in which they lost again that they
really had the entire time right and
should have won
Arizona is gonna sit back and go the
futures here and they're gonna go man
that kid threw a fourth-quarter
touchdown to Chad Williams to tie it up
against Seattle a team that we can't
beat I like Arizona here to cover the
points I also think Arizona might win
the game outright in fact I'm gonna say
right now I rizona wins the game are you
really yeah all right I'll let me just
get it out of the way I am gonna go $100
in the Cardinals as well oh here I was
thinking I was crazy what's that
oh stop mr. 49er don't don't dig for
gold there that's a dangerous little oh
that's a dangerous little gas gas bubble
don't do that I'm letting you know
okay so I don't even know what the hell
that was nobody remember when that was
gonna be a huge part of the Simpson love
go show we were like let's build around
mascot battles we just need to get live
animals in the office yes you're right
that's that's what it comes down to it
we can get the animals in then we can as
long as we treat them correctly of
course okay so all your points are very
real about the rosin thing like you have
an organization that's going we need to
make our face of our franchise look good
that's right you're right and the thing
about yes the 49ers are gonna be
underwhelmed that's like Oh CJ Beathard
yeah he'll do a lot of good things again
but well he'll find some way to screw it
up in the end or you know whatever it
may be and I'm not even blaming him
because it wasn't his fault that I
didn't drop the ball on the 5-yard line
the ball went up in the air and it got
returned for 80 yards and totally
changed the game 49ers defense stinks
you can throw on them we know that the
Cardinals defense is not very good
either
the 49ers it up a lot of points that's
the thing that scares me when you get
down close with the 49ers or even past
midfield you could score touchdowns on
them they're a little over-aggressive
with the things they do in coverage at
times I think that scares me and yes I
think the best thrower on the field is
Josh Rosen certainly the the other way I
look at it is the 49ers offense
it is good CJ Beathard or not whoever it
is it's always good is cuz Kyle's
amazing is amazing and you want to talk
about bad run defense I'm pretty sure
Arizona is the worst run defense of
football but I'll just double-check that
oh they're second or worse only behind
the Lions a hundred and forty-one yards
per game
that's scary against Kyle Shanahan yes
it really is the the Arizona Cardinals
interior part of their D line is just I
mean you know they lost some Kim D Chi
and some of those guys like sorry
negative ghostrider that pick didn't
work either way I'm going to pick the
49ers to win the game
31 to 28 but I think this is very close
and I think it will be like a last three
minute drive to win the game for the
49ers for a touchdown or game-winning
field goal to put them over the edge but
I just don't think they
the four points yeah I don't like I
don't like Beathard covered I like
Beathard battling yeah it
alright guys 425 Eastern on Sunday the
one two and one Minnesota Vikings on the
road visiting the two and to
Philadelphia Eagles
it'll be a balmy 80 degrees in
Philadelphia on Sunday spread in this
game is Philadelphia minus three Adam
left go we'll start with you Corey
Clemente Sproles still day today and I
really think the Eagles miss them a lot
in that game I think that the running
back throws are a huge part of their
offense and those are the two guys that
actually can do it Dalvin cook there's a
lot of people in line right now getting
upset he's telling people he's not a
hundred and the Vikings are still trying
to play him a lot he's in Jewish issue
trae Waynes concussion did not practice
this week yet all of the stats make me
want to take Philly yeah Philly since
week 16 in 2016 at home 11 and 1 at home
8 and 4 against the spread the Vikings
are 1 5 & 1 in their last seven against
the spread Minnesota has a road dog
under Zimmer though 14 and 7 against the
spread third best of the NFL since 2014
and there's this whole NFC Championship
revenge Everson Griffin's out I am
taking Minnesota plus 3 what a loser in
Philadelphia what a loser
I hope I'm wrong
Minnesota played last Thursday and I saw
an offense against Aaron Donald that was
able to put up points and I know the
Rams defense has had a lot more holes
than the Eagles defense did and the
evils defense even though they kind of
risked a little bit against Tennessee is
a little bit more sound than the Rams
defense I think Minnesota is more
desperate right now than Philadelphia is
agree I also think that Kirk Cousins is
going to have a few big plays against
Philadelphia and I think that with that
defense I don't think that stops anytime
soon I think feeling digs I think
they're gonna get a few big plays that
can go off and I do think that Minnesota
is going to be able to extend
drives against Philadelphia and I think
that Vikings defense is gonna take a
long hard look at themselves after
watching themself for the last week and
a half just on TV because every time you
watch Rams highlights
you're watching Anthony Barr sprinting
70 yards
you're watching Todd Gurley Minnesota
hasn't been smacked like that since the
week before I guess Buffalo but that was
that was suffering that was worth game
those were self-imposed wounds right and
they felt bad and all they've moved on
from Everson I would have to imagine I
think that the Eagles are gonna win this
game but I think it's like 2120 and
that's why I have in Minnesota I think
three points in this game I think these
two teams are even right now I really do
yeah and uh that's where I'm going and I
don't know if Carson's a hundred percent
back yet yeah okay I grew I'm also
probably trying to motion agree with a
lot of what you said there I think
there's a lot of things to look at let's
also not forget the John de Filippo
factor that he's in Minnesota and he
knows Jim Schwartz and all that all the
things that the big thing to me okay I
think when I look at Vikings offense
Eagles defense it scares me just a
little bit is again the interior part of
the offensive line for the Vikings can
be scary yeah this could be even scarier
than the Rams because you're just a
little more of a hulking like power D
line it's not is necessarily the
athletic get like the box and who is
better than Donald it's yeah nobody I
mean no it's nobody in there but but
it's also like I look at like second and
long third down when you put all your
variations in there it's gonna still be
very tough I think you're four is
probably better than the ramps for okay
oh yeah I just came with a hot taking
even mean - yeah I know I mean you say
Graham Bennett who nada and koksar know
Graham Bennett long and [ __ ] I think so
yes something like that I mean yeah
Michael Bennett still pops on on film
I'm just hoping our meathead friend Jim
Schwartz doesn't go Blitz happy three
interceptions
I've been three sacks last week one
interception
okay of the three sacks two of them were
four-man rush the third sack yes they
blitzed but
Benna just beat the center straight up
the Blitz had nothing to do with helping
him the interception happened when the
Eagles played coverage Jim Schwartz has
this fascination sometimes that like the
quarterback should never sit there and
be able to read the defense like are you
kidding me this is 2018 like the
quarterback is gonna drop back every now
and then and have a little time off a
play-action pass or something like that
he just goes to meathead for me at times
where it's just like I got a destroy the
play for negative five okay great you
you might do that but you also give up
seventy over your head a lot and that's
disturbing and jaylen Mills isn't that
good so stop putting him in man-to-man
coverage
like he's Deion [ __ ] Sanders all
right I'm sick of that [ __ ] with these
defensive coordinators oh well on the
it's like the tight end blocking the
great pastoral wall on the board he
covers a man-to-man we're good there
oh yeah except for the actual people who
are in that matchup we forgot about that
part of the equation drives me crazy
about the Eagles it really does okay
clip that and I want to say that the
Philadelphia I got it okay I just wrote
down Sims Eagles yeah so then the other
thing I do think Carson Wentz I mean
your pass protection has bothered me a
little especially last week I mean
Carson Wentz holy crap did he take a lot
of hits last week he really did I mean
damn but there is no Everson Griffin and
that makes me feel better
I gotta think that offensive line looks
at it and goes what the hell were we
doing okay and like we got to help this
guy out
Vikings run defense is not special I do
I would hope you can run to keep them
honest and I'm not gonna bet that Zimmer
changes his DNA on coaching I'm just not
I'm betting that he's gonna stay with
what I've seen him do for the last ten
years cuz he shown me that he doesn't
change and I don't think he's gonna
happen now in a bye week so you mean the
guy that almost lost his eye and still
coached as stubborn yeah right right
so I'm putting $100 on the Vikings Oh
cuz I'm with you I'm with you
assemblé to take over thy Philadelphia
freedom Ben it's ok if we lose just make
it by less than three I think they are
the more desperate team I do think the
NFC champion thing comes into play and
I'm picking the Eagles to win the game
but I picked it to be 26 24 that type of
football I'm gonna say that's really
quick I know we need to catch up not
only do you have D Flippo familiar yeah
Kirk Cousins has always played well
against the Eagles yeah you're right
so now not only this is not new for him
he's used to this yes yeah I think
that's a benefit I was just I was just
gonna say are we gonna let Kris off
we're calling it the freedom Bell I know
sorry I totally choked on it as I was
saying and I was like I'm saying the
wrong thing but you want to try history
major up yours
were you a history major I was through a
lot of history barks at Texas would you
mind bringing in your degree
oh darn it I didn't have a degree damn
I'm a worthless person the degrees are
you know they really make you they make
the difference maybe just bringing some
of the text books you read while you're
in college
oh I sold those you sold them Brent
money cash out the back door yep all
right 25 here guys I really even want to
got the text okay you didn't need him
for 25 LA Rams for know on the road
visiting the two and to Seattle Seahawks
spreading this game here is Rams minus
seven just checking to see if there's
been any movement on this line opened at
seven and a half down to seven so that's
where we are
the injuries Dominique easily out for
the year there's a chance that Mark
Baron plays his first this year Seattle
Chris Carson is back
KJ right is not Michael Kendricks is
suspended hmm for some reason it's weird
though now they're suspending him and
they weren't suspending him before I
guess why because he got the final
guilty play right I think that's I mean
they they said they what was it what
happened there's nothing happened
nothing happened nothing okay they just
decided all right all of the trends tell
me to take Seattle as a home dog this is
rare we are witnessing something we have
not seen in really eight years under
Pete Carroll Seattle has only been a
home dog of seven or more
it's two times in eight years so that's
64 games they've been an underdog that's
I think I lied no 8 times 8 to 60 64
games so 2 games and they're 1 in one
straight up and against the spread
Seattle as a home dog since 2011 9 and 3
against the spread and I say this
because I said this last year when the
Rams went to Seattle and in this first
year of head coach Sean McVeigh beat the
Seahawks for their worst loss in
centrally Link field history kid genius
42 to 7 kid genius I am putting $200 so
if he can dice up the Vikings defense on
short week what is he gonna do to the
Seahawks defense with 10 days yeah very
well very good judge very good job very
very very good job ok yeah I don't even
know you flustered me there why are your
points
no no he's good he's good he's good yeah
yeah a lot of good points I think the
the Rams are the best team in football
we know that the Seahawks okay their
defense is actually 7th in football
right now it's been good but I would
also mind you they've played the worst
offenses in the sport really I mean they
play their names I mean they played the
Cowboys yes they played the Cardinals
yes ok the Bears move the ball true
Brisky just tricked it off a few times
that's a game right so don't forget
about this some wide open guy exactly
right and Case Keenum
had plays - he just took some aggressive
shots and threw some dumb interceptions
he threw three interceptions in that
game and they still lost the Seahawks oh
so think about that so I'm not sold on
the Seahawks defense is like a top ten
defense they're not there's no way
they'll be top ten so you could just
forget about that this is also the first
game after the old Thomas middle thing
that's right so and you can run on the
Seahawks 122 yards a game they're
letting those are running back for the
Rams
Oh mmm the best running back in high
ball four thank you I'll take Todd
Gurley for $100
ok I'm going with the Rams - oh yeah
jealous they went 200 I am because I
didn't want to have to root against the
ramps and how I might have to but it's
not beneficial you'd still lose a
hundred I guess you're right
yeah I know so but damn I so it's only
week five yeah I think I was gonna take
the Seahawks I didn't know okay I just
mad that you up me with the money that's
what I'm mad you have a long time to get
back in the greenside you anymore I know
that what if I don't last two weeks
you've been like it's it's a show it's
fun yeah that's good money on that game
he's got in my ear we've been like I
wanna go hold on
that's that entire rape talent I've
wanted to go a hundred right and he's
just like in no way did I advocate for
the four hundred dollar bet on the
dolphin he didn't for you but he was
saying I should get away and take some
chance why don't you say if your gosh
lives okay quite the consigliere
I think the Rams win this game 32 21
okay and yeah I am the Seahawks offense
is nothing special I know there's no
Aqib Talib oh gosh no they don't I'm
only worried about the Tyler Lockett
shots yeah and I think Wade Phillips
will know that that's maybe the one
thing that can beat him and then I I
just don't see it Rams win 3021 let's go
all right guys Sunday Night Football
here Dallas Cowboys 2 & 2 or do we want
do we really quickly want to talk about
the fact that the Rams have allowed 54
points in the last two games well let's
see it was the bike butchers and the
Vikings okay those are at the same point
they've also scored 33 34 35 30
I don't think the Seahawks are capable
either do I they don't SIG's right yeah
the other teams were realizing like our
defense we can't stop them yes
so we need to push the boundaries of our
offense and the the seahawks boundaries
are like Russell can you do more amazing
things for us sorry Sunday Night
Football
2 & 2 Dallas on the road in Texas
visiting Houston one in three spread for
this game Houston - three and a half at
home left go we'll start with you
alright what a my favorite games the
week will fuller is quote we'll see how
it goes this week I think that's huge
area Aaron Colvin is another guy I mean
it's just it's every week he's I don't
like in the words of Evans hope I don't
like when speed guys have hamstring no
skew speed guys are like cheetahs are
like racehorses if they feel the
slightest twinge there
they're thrown off Erin Colvin is out
for the Texans we may see a cave on West
Webster debut Texans ok um David Irving
is back the Dallas defense that already
has DeMarcus Lawrence and two great
man-to-man corners that Simms professed
on Wednesdays POD inch adobea woozy a
and Byron Jones now has another pass
rusher to possibly scare deshaun Watson
in night games in their last 20 Houston
is 6 and 14 in night games since dak
started for Dallas they're 10 and 2 I'd
like to place a hundred dollars on the
Dallas Cowboys to cover three and a half
like that 1101 from that voice he'll are
the Texans favored by three and a half
over anybody why because they allowed
Andrew Luck to get back into a game that
they scored a bunch of points in like
how are they favored three and a half
over Ezekiel Elliott yeah I hear ya I
mean you know III don't know III think
there's some things here that you gotta
watch out for just a little bit okay
well okay fine I'm going a hundred
dollars on the Cowboys okay okay do you
Texan howdy ha - Mikey Haws better than
URI ha what's the Texan sound Nick don't
think there is one well I guess it's
gonna have to be yeehaw we got to get
that one up yeehaw like a sub
he's a southerner Texan detection Sheila
Houston the Texans should be
everything's bigger in Texas we stole
the Longhorn off their helmet and we
made it a bigger Longhorn
your breakdown of this game okay sorry
alright
the Texans defense has not been special
we know that to this point but they
showed special things last week and
their run defense is pretty damn good
their past events has been the issue
okay great and Dallas could not take
advantage of that exactly right so that
scares me and we saw the unveiling of
two of my favorite beasts
what and they'll be subjective er cloudy
is finally ready to be unveiled on the
state of Texas and I'm so excited
because Jadeveon looked amazing I mean
he's the master of the [ __ ] up play
and it showed up last week nice right
I'm crying laughing over here and I also
think they look at and go oh okay uh the
Alice wants to run the ball I mean these
are like these are a DJ reader and
company like they got pride they're not
gonna baby hear about this Dallas old
line all the time I have a hard time
thinking Dallas is gonna run the ball on
them even though it's a slight issue and
like you said even though past offenses
their issue
Dallas is easy to figure out what they
want to do in the pass game and I think
Romeo Crennel and company will be able
to slow that down what about Watson so
versus the Dallas it is scary it is
definitely scary I don't know what to
say the Texans offense I think as a
whole is better than the Dallas offense
I am very much worried about them being
able to protect deshaun Watson and I'm
putting my faith I took the Cowboys for
the spread because it was three and a
half I had the Texans winning the game
22 17 I think they're gonna win this
game
III do think they're kind of at point is
huge they're kind of yes and they're
kind of in a desperate mode too right am
i right are they there one and three
right yeah okay coming off a win coming
off a win Dallas just beat Detroit yes
and Dallas just beat Detroit and
everybody's telling them Houston they
just found the full overtime I know
that's scary too but I'm just going more
on Romeo Bill O'Brien having a few more
schematic Allah makes me want to pick
the cowboys and that make like if your
big argument is Romeo Crennel and Bill
O'Brien right then I'm going Cowboys
okay that's fine doesn't that make sense
well yeah I hear you I'm going the
Cowboys to I just think the Texans will
find a few more plays out of deshaun
Watson and company on the offense is out
of the ball or dak Prescott sach thumb
bull kind of thing I just see that
happening more than sac fumble deshaun
Watson something like that that's where
I'm going this is a very close game and
I would not bet money on this all right
guys last game of the week Monday Night
Football the Washington is 2 in 1 hey
Washington the Washington's are 2 & 1
heading on the road to face the 3 & 1
New Orleans Saints spread in the
game is New Orleans - six-and-a-half
sims we'll start with you
okay the Washington Redskins hey their
defense is good we know that Greg
mineski I got a lot of respect for him
they haven't let up a lot of points to
the third ranked defense in football
right now hundred and eighty seven yards
a game they're allowing in the past
fourteen point seven points it's really
good you know what the problem is
they've played three of the most simple
pass offenses in the game right now the
Cardinals the Colts and one-legged Aaron
Rodgers so I'm not totally buying into
their defenses like you know the
eighties Redskins with Charles Mann and
Dexter Manley quite yet I do like a lot
of what I see they're certainly now the
Saints we know their offense is
dangerous the run game is for real and
here they come and I'm actually very
excited to watch this old line square
off against the Alabama duo of the
Washington Redskins it's gonna be very
cool the Saints offense is really good
though and I do think they'll be able to
move the ball I don't think it's gonna
be like 38 points moving the ball but
enough the thing that I look at and I
was encouraged with what I saw with the
Saints last week they are doing some
different stuff on the defensive side of
the ball they did not play as much
man-to-man and I would hope that
continues this week to mix up some of
those coverages and yeah their D line is
coming alive slowly but surely which is
disappointed me it is coming alive so I
am putting $100 on the Redskins it's
just six and a half so a little too much
for me and I think the Redskins have the
type of offense and weapons and
offensive line to be well-rounded in
their attack to give this a very close
football game the Saints win the game
but I'm gonna say 24 to 20 mm Patrick
Robinson up for the year Washington
coming off of a bye last year the Saints
were favored to beat Washington by like
seven yeah and remember Washington was
up 31 to 16 in the fourth quarter right
in New Orleans and New Orleans came back
and won that game by throws from Chris
Thompson broke his leg in that game - it
was yeah here's where it gets
interesting
both teams stink in primetime yeah last
five games in primetime the Saints are
Owen five Jay Gruden with Washington
though it's like historic
one in six straight up Washington's last
15 games on Monday Night Football there
are two and thirteen cheese-less 15
games on Monday Night Football 13 it's
one of the gamblers favorite things to
bet on they gave me my reason to eat of
the Year last year was it the Raiders
wha that Washington Chiefs game oh and
the Cho that was the baddest speed of
all time on for the touchdown they were
laterally I know I've got like $800 on
the Redskins and they had the game cover
of the entire time Mark Ingram is back I
am going I'm going a hundred dollars on
Washington - this feels a lot like last
year yeah and it's Washington coming off
a bye which kind of scares me but you
know I this is a kind of team that I
actually like having Alex Smith against
New Orleans once you to take shots and
they want you because they want their
offense back on the field Alex Smith
could this could be the Chris Thompson
Jordan Reed work in the middle Jameson
browner keeping Drew Brees off the field
now this is one quick question yeah Drew
Brees is expected to pass the right
Manning right on Monday night yeah when
there's a record up for grabs how does
that impact either team ah the Redskins
how many yours yards is you need like
200 what do you know how many is good
again yeah he's gonna get no I think
what it's really gonna do is everyone's
gonna feel the electricity in the
stadium that's the first thing and who
does that benefit I think they've
benefits the Saints yeah I do
it's close uh the Redskins are certainly
gonna be like damn we don't want them to
shatter this on us but yeah I think the
Saints it does it benefits that just six
snap was too much right I think this
Washington teams about better than
people think I agree you know it's it's
the second year really the third year in
a row where that's the case yeah they
got a bye people forgot about him in the
Saints went to New York and beat the
Giants by 20-point the Redskins and the
Carolina Panthers got forgotten about
last week because of their bye weeks
yeah all right guys before we wrap it up
here I'll just quickly go through recap
and go through the disagreements left go
you got to get ready for LOX here you
got your GTL picked out cool so
disagreements from this week Tennessee -
three and a half Sims you took the
Titans left go going Buffalo in that
game Denver New York Jets
was that first one sodium Tennessee
Buffalo okay Denver and the Jets Sims
you took Denver plus one left go took
the Jets minus one we've got an actual
$20 on that game I am holding left goes
20 for the weekend I will try not to
spend it Green Bay at Detroit Sims you
took the Packers minus one left go went
with the Lions that game Giants Panthers
Sims you have the Giants left go you
took the Panthers Miami Cincinnati Sims
you took Miami plus six and a half left
go took Cincinnati minus six and a half
Oakland
Chargers Sims going with the Raiders
left go going with the Chargers spread
that game is five and a half and and
everything else you guys are going on oh
so we have some good ones different game
this week and biggest bet of the week
this week left go $200 on the Rams minus
seven and what was this other big bag at
a 180 bet right the one have been 200
tonight on New England I have 200 on the
Rams and 180 on vault all right left go
locks for this week all right so I have
three that I'm definitely I have I have
I have three that I'm definitely locking
and I need your guy's help on the other
one if you may yep I got you all right I
know a lot about football you go okay
the ones I'm definitely doing I'm
definitely doing the Rams minus seven at
Seattle I'm definitely doing Baltimore
minus three at Cleveland I think I'm
doing
Pittsburgh - three versus Atlanta okay
okay up top those are the three that I'm
feeling pretty good about okay
the two that I'm not sure which one I
want to do Jacksonville plus three at
Kansas City Carolina - seven against the
Giants I would in my informed opinion
much rather bet against the Giants than
I would against Patrick mahomes you got
you've been burned three times already
this year betting on Patrick mahomes or
betting against Patrick mahomes I even
need you Sims yeah no no go
I just desperation I wouldn't bet on
Elena in Pittsburgh
yes that was a question - so where do
you feel more confident too
Jacksonville at Kansas City over
Pittsburgh Atlanta I do I never trust
bad football teams and then the only
other one I want to put in there was
Minnesota plus three but I don't know if
I went on the national account me
picking against the Eagles yeah but do
you feel more confident Minnesota plus 3
then Jacksonville Kansas City I don't so
then I think my left ko locks are gonna
be Rams Ravens Rams Ravens Panthers
Jaguars and there it is Sims they've
convinced me because Pittsburgh Atlanta
Atlanta could win that game by 17 Ben
throws one pick and also another down 21
to 7 and it's a shootout and they never
catch up whatever feel good about
Jacksonville in this spot that's the
reason why I'm willing to bet against
Patrick mahomes and also like the public
is obsessed with Patrick mahomes right
now I'm just telling you my two cents on
this and I know I've been wrong before
but he has never seen anything like he's
about to see on Sunday and do you think
with all those badass mofos down in
there and Jackson everybody's telling
them how dangerous Patrick's you don't
think you guys we're coming after you we
got to wrap this thing up but there's
one thing we have left to do we do you
know what that is I do this is your part
of the show here guaranteed to lose hit
that music Nick it's time to talk about
the teams that have no chance and we
start off Simms on Thursday Thursday
night hey it's Andrew Luck and it seems
like he's by himself out there tonight
oh that's the usual everybody on their
teams hurt and the patrons have turned
it around
sorry Colts it's gonna be a long weekend
you're gonna lose a newing second team
on guaranteed to lose nobody circles the
wagons like the Buffalo Bills and ain't
gonna be circling this week they're
gonna still be going in a square pattern
they can't figure out the circles quite
yet Buffalo I think is up there as the
worst team in football it dawn is the
Arizona Cardinals and the Titans have
been a pleasant surprise
sorry Buffalo see you next week on
guaranteed to lose all right next one
guaranteed to lose
been on this team for the first time in
like 30 games yeah back to the list I'm
back Oh better because it's the
Baltimore Ravens coming to town and
Cleveland sorry you're guaranteed to
lose you're going to lose you know why
cuz I said so I am the Oracle next up on
guaranteed to lose their quarterback is
still Eli Manning oh man that's right
and that's a big reason I'm picking the
Giants to lose sorry New York Giants Cam
Newton and company have had a week off
this game might be closed for a little
while but Carolina's tougher they're
better and their quarterback will stand
in the pocket and make a throw and let's
round out guaranteed to lose to the west
coast we go oh sorry Seattle you gonna
lose to the Rams because kid genius and
his team of all-stars are coming to town
Sean McVeigh Todd Gurley Gulf Oh Brandon
cooks Oh Aaron Donald and DOMA could sue
Marcus Peters who the hell to the
Seattle Seahawks have a bunch of older
guys or old Thomas is not there and it's
only Russell Wilson sorry Seattle the
Rams are kings of the West momma's let
goes mama said so hey gotta get her in
there I like after going five and Oh
last week here our Sims is five it is
the colts it is the bills it is the
Browns it's the Giants and it's the
Seahawks and for the first time that I
can remember left go is picking one of
the teams to win it seems has guaranteed
to lose open bills Titans was like what
biking's are getting revenge for the NFC
Championship Game then the bills are
getting revenge for the Music City
miracle for Sims peace out homies for
fender good evening everybody
I am the lef koe man and we will holla
holla holla at you Sunday good luck on
your survivor Kools good luck in fantasy
good luck betting my left go lux don't
embrace the motion I'm back it's gonna
be amazing
and survivor pools he meant to say not
cool pools yes see you guys